et pour en parler nous recevons thierry
val avocat au barreau de paris bonjour m
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
on rentre aujourd'hui dans la cinquième
semaine de grève des avocats on sent
qu'il ya un véritable malaise au sein de
la profession quelles sont les raisons
exactes
les avocats sont effectivement en colère
c'est un mouvement inédit plus d'un
puits d'un mois déjà de deux
manifestations de grèves de défense
massive en comparution immédiate pour
protester contre ce régime de retraite
qu'on veut nous imposer alors que nous
avons un régime autonome qui
fonctionnent très bien on l'a entendu
nous sommes indépendants nous sommes
aussi solidaire puisque on a aujourd'hui
100 millions d'euros qui tous les ans on
malgré notre autonomie versés à la peau
pour le pour les régimes généraux donc
pourquoi casser un système qui
fonctionne pourquoi vouloir mélanger des
libéraux avec des salariés nous l'impact
et dans le régime universel n'a pas de
sens
aujourd'hui on nous apporte absolument
aucune solution pour compenser les
effets absolument désastreux que
pourrait avoir cette ce régime
puisqu'on estime avec des hausses de
cotisations de 14 à 28 % que près de
20000 avocat mettraient la clef sous la
porte
donc ça veut dire une désertification de
la justice qui va s'occuper des dd plus
des plus démunis des aides juridiques de
l'aide juridictionnelle des
consultations gratuites et que l'on que
beaucoup d'avocats fonds se sont pas les
ténors du barreau qui vont être impactés
forcément et ça va être les petits
cabinets de 10 de proximité et on a
beaucoup beaucoup d'inquiétude par
rapport à ça on veut précarisés notre
profession alors que nous avons
absolument aujourd'hui une quête qui
fonctionne alors depuis le début de
cette mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites certains corps de métiers ont
gardé
leur régime ils ont obtenu à gamme cause
c'est ce que vous souhaitez ce que nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui
li foutais là foutez la paix aux avocats
on n'a rien demandé
on a absolument aucune vocation à
rentrer dans ce régime universel
nous voulons rester dans ce régime et si
on veut modifier les choses qu'on ne
leur apporte des solutions pérennes et
précise
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de réponse
il y avait hier une réunion qui était
prévue avec le premier ministre a été
décalée à décaler manifestement il avait
autre chose à faire que que de s'occuper
de cette de cette réunion et donc les
décalés à demain
c'est peut-être voilà aussi un manque
manque d'intérêt peut être de là de la
part on l'a vu avec la garde des sceaux
qui reste extrêmement fermé sur ses
positions et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il ya quelques
négociations que ce soit on nous dit
c'est pas négociable
c'est pas du tout négociables d'un
effectivement de l'autre côté non plus
donc nous allons continuer à nous battre
jusqu'au bout
justement comment vous réagissez quand
vous entendez que voilà les les
policiers vont garder leur statut que
certains métiers voilà ne bouge pas
finalement face à cette réforme et et
vous vous battez le pavé depuis
maintenant plus d'un mois et demi oui et
c'est pas de gaîté de coeur parce que
quand on voit des gestes symboliques de
jeter nos robes de brûler des codes
donc tout ça bien sûr nous fait nous
fait aussi extrêmement mal au coeur
c'est extrêmement symbolique et c'est
difficile pour nous de paralyser aussi
quelque part le fonctionnement de la
justice mais c'est là aujourd'hui la
règle du jeu puisqu'on nous impose un
bras de fer nous allons aller jusqu'au
bout pour la défense des libertés pour
la défense de nos droits
parce que bon c'est pas un réflexe
corporatiste c'est vraiment on a un
système qui fonctionne il faut penser
aux avocats aux petits l'avocat à la
justice en général et aujourd'hui ce
régime autonome qui qui a été mis en
place depuis des décennies fonctionne
très bien ne coûte rien à l'état ne
coûte rien au contribuable est
aujourd'hui permet d'assurer une
retraite décente en parité totale pour
tous les avocats de france et ça il faut
absolument qu'elles soient préservées
alors vous allez manifester cet après
midi il y aura également dans le cortège
des anciens gré
des pilotes de ligne vous parlez d'un
bras de fer mais on a vu auparavant le
bras de fer entre les gilet jaune par
exemple et le gouvernement plus de plus
d'un an que ça dure ça n'a rien donné
est-ce que la situation là risquent de
continuer duré en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de détermination chez les
avocats je le sens au quotidien beaucoup
de confrères sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement donc déterminés à poursuivre
la lutte
nous sommes en colère nous sommes
vraiment nous avons vocation à préserver
nos notre notre régime auquel nous nous
tenons il est totalement impossible qu'
on puisse être aussi aux sourds à nos à
nos revendications de la part du
gouvernement alors que dans d'autres
pays on a parfaitement su différencier
les libéraux des salariés en espagne en
italie ça fonctionne comme ça ça
fonctionne très bien
donc pourquoi en france ferait
différemment donc tous nous sommes
toujours déterminés et nous poursuivrons
la lutte jusqu'au moment où une
revendication seront jugées
insatisfaisantes pour nous merci
beaucoup m thierry valade avoir répondu
à nos questions je vous rappelle que
vous êtes avocat au barreau de passe